[Music]
[Applause]
all right
happy thursday everyone what a glorious
time to be alive
especially if you're me
so once again we're seeing the left go
after speech left wing ngos are now
coming after elon musk for buying
twitter that's him on the left
in case you're normal and have no idea
what an ngo is it stands for no good
organization
pretty clever
there are non-profit groups that claim
to be independent of any government but
aim to push radical agendas like no cash
bail and now censorship imagine a group
even more obnoxious and less accountable
than government employees and this week
the ngo sent a letter urging a boycott
of twitter if musk takes over the
company its backers include former
clinton operatives billionaire george
soros as well as get this the european
union yes the european union signed a
letter
the ukrainians must be thrilled
to hear that the eu's got their
priorities straight sure we're under
constant russian attack but someone was
mean to chrissy teigen
how's she doing you also you know hell
signed this letter
the canadian government
is this what governments do
sign letters demanding advertisers to
boycott an american company i'm sorry
canada we never expect america to sign a
letter boycotting beavers
but let's not forget it was the canadian
prime minister who called canadian
truckers nazis which is about as hateful
as you could get although maybe not
quite as hateful as donning blackface
if justin trudeau is worried about
speech he should look in the mirror but
the last thing he wants to do is argue
with a person of color
i get why he hates twitter any kind of
speech about him is usually going to be
critical because he sucks he's the worst
thing to come from canada since neil
young's voice
even even moose are thinking do we know
a realtor in tampa
musk responded to the letter with a
tweet asking who funds these
organizations that want to control your
access to information let's investigate
he added that sunlight is the best
disinfectant
which i disagree with try getting rid of
gangrene with a sun lamp
the letter was signed by more than 26
organizations and it claims that musk's
purchase or what they call a takeover
will further quote toxify our
information ecosystem and worse it would
be a direct threat to public safety
especially among those already most
vulnerable and marginalized so wait are
we talking about free speech on twitter
or defunding the police
they don't think twice about vulnerable
people when they get rid of cash bail
but allowing free speech on twitter that
will that'll leave a trail of dead
bodies from here to silicon valley
threats public safety you'd think you
were walking in chicago after 4 p.m
but this is the same fear trotted out
against anyone they want to eliminate
from discourse and as usual it's in the
name of the marginalized but has a white
wealthy leftist ever asked a
marginalized group what they really want
of course not they wouldn't dare go into
a marginalized neighborhood they might
get stabbed by a guy who's back on the
street thanks to their own policies
fact is polling shows how marginalized
groups pretty much want what everybody
else wants a good job a house freedom
from crime freedom of speech and of
course an autographed signed photo of
greg gutfeld
that's what everyone wants
everyone except for the very idiots
pretending to speak for marginalized
groups and it helps explain the lurch
away from debate towards censorship and
while boycotts have been around forever
these are now not about a product but
about silencing any opposition using the
social media mob it's a level of
extortion that would make tony soprano
drop his gaba ghoul
this group also claims that an
advertiser risks association with a
platform amplifying hate extremism
health misinformation and conspiracy
theorists
wait maybe this letter was meant for cnn
they also claim that under musk's
management twitter risks becoming a
cesspool of misinformation
that's like saying taking a piss risks
stinking up a times square porta
potty i know that for a fact twitter
risks becoming a cesspool of
misinformation what is it already
when someone mentions twitter you don't
exactly picture guys in powdered wigs
sitting in a venerable hall debating the
importance of the protestant work ethic
on a capitalist society while having
afternoon tea
saying must could make twitter a
cesspool of untruths is like complaining
about diarrhea before you've been to
chipotle
[Applause]
thinking about it
so who's behind this it appears it's
three organizations which are all
left-wing outfits jesse layrick a
co-founder of accountable tech once
served as a spokesperson for hillary
clinton's presidential campaign so he
definitely knows about a toxic ecosystem
media matters is a bitter den of
couchbound leftists spends nearly all
their time watching fox and tweeting
about it no wonder musk scares him so
much he might make these lonely losers
work harder or have a heart attack but
the left-wing media has always been
about monopolizing speech they're not
even trying to hide it anymore
tonight on the chess news network
david brooks here with the test news
network home of the fair and focus
debate we are not swayed by public
opinion and we have the ratings to prove
it we have two people here on opposing
sides of an issue miss how do you feel
about elon musk and twitter
billionaires and their corporate
interests have no rights to affect
political discourse in this country i
read that in the washington post oh well
said and you sir support elon what's it
like to hate minorities well wait a
minute no i i would never say
what i meant to say
miss any thoughts
we are flirting with fascism in this
country and lady liberty did not consent
okay well i need to
i can't even
there you have it folks kind of fair and
focused debate you'll only see here on
the chess news network back to you grab
[Applause]
[Music]
the creepiest thing i've ever seen
but it's kind of appealing
of course now the left are no different
than students on campus who shut down
speakers or shout down speakers they
won't tolerate competition the problem
here musk doesn't care he doesn't need
advertisers to make twitter work he's
got all he needs to make it a success a
belief in free speech a few extra
billions he found under the couch
cushions and balls the size of caitlyn
jenner
larry
[Applause]
tonight yes
he turned al-qaeda's number one into a
pile of number two
former navy seal and co-author of the
brand new book the way forward rob
o'neal
she's so bright her future has to wear
shades financial analyst heather zuma
norton antivirus can't save you from his
infectious laughter comedian and co-host
of the jim norton and sam roberts show
on siriusxm jim norton
[Applause]
she's like a q-tip thin white and can be
harmful to your ears
fox news contributor cat tip
jim
jim it's always great to see you and a
delight to see you i could see you all
the time if i could i see you all i
don't ever want you to leave my eyeballs
thank you you never leave my dreams
[Laughter]
do you like elon musk and what would you
do if you had that kind of money what
would you buy to fix
i wouldn't buy anything to fix unless
there were a lot of broken hookers
[Laughter]
there are
that answers your question doesn't it
yeah uh no i love elon musk i love what
he's doing to act like twitter is this
great place already i mean it's a
terrible play like yesterday somebody
uploaded this video of uh madison
cawthran in a hotel room humping my face
it is so unfair he's just a young kid
having fun
um rob good to see you kill anybody
lately
not in front of a camera long long time
so what do you make of this uh this uh
open letter or this signed letter from
canada a country is actually telling us
about free speech well it's the same
names too with you know canada's
involved the eu george soros involved
the obamas the clintons david axelrod's
involved and with hillary clinton
involved it surprised me that um you
know she she's going after someone who
wants to colonize mars when she married
someone who simply wants to put a finger
on your anus
[Applause]
but i mean but
but i'm sure bill the whole time it's
like you're going getting getting rid of
the internet keep your damn hands off
grinder
don't come to me after that please oh
heather
heather you don't have any sex jokes do
you no
i didn't i wasn't expecting that you
know you know um okay so heather i'm
gonna give you the the business question
here this is these these boycotts have
been used uh in exactly the same way as
a threat to silence fox to silence
tucker they did it to joe rogan do you i
was just like
don't put our music on spotify and they
and then now they're doing it to us how
do these things ever actually work these
like economics because then you'll just
create another platform but that's an
interesting question given that you take
the world's richest man and instead of
creating his own platform he has truly
billions of dollars not trillions not
yet yeah but billions of dollars and he
decides to buy twitter
that just goes to show that there is a
monopoly in social media because why
wouldn't he just create his own instead
of by what is a liberal platform that's
a great point and he wants free speech
it goes to show you how the liberal
media and the liberal mob really is
controlling what is put out there and i
think
americans should be able to see both
sides he says he invites his his most
crucial uh critical enemies and he wants
everyone that disagrees with him not
hate speech but he invites their voices
also so that americans can decide for
themselves i don't think americans are
dumb when presented with all the facts
let us decide for ourselves
yes
well foot young lady and not a single
perverted sex joke
no
kat uh before i ask you a serious
question i have to commend you on your
latest character
quite possibly the freakiest creature
i've ever seen
but somehow i feel like i know that
person or i've met that person or i've
seen that person somewhere in in
collapse how did you get the twitching
down
um i think it came more naturally to me
than i thought it would
so i have a side question and i was
thinking about this
we always hear about george soros at the
root of all these things whether it's
these progressive da's or in this in
this case this uh anti-free speech
letter do you think he is aware
that this is going on is he like because
he's like in his late 80s does he know
that these organizations that he are
that he's funding are actually doing
that stuff you probably don't know the
yeah i mean we don't hang out
[Laughter]
not not even once not even once yeah
have you tried calling him
no
yeah but you know the phone works both
ways yeah that's true that's true um
is there uh what what do you what do you
make of this the fact that the this
letter was signed by the eu
the all the uh oh
our our fans media matters that's yeah
media matters i i really don't believe
that they are passionate about civility
on the internet yes given how many times
anyone who has worked here they've had
multiple times where they've twisted
something you've said and then you know
presented it in some incendiary way so
that people will go after you right and
attack you but really reading too much
into twitter particularly mentions and
stuff like that i it's like a form of
self-harm yes you're gonna find horrible
stuff but they say you know it's not a
safe space for women
and i am a woman
um
and like and the term like you know the
list of things bothering me you know at
john
6 4 6 4 6 2 2 calling me a [ __ ] is like
at the bottom of the things that worry
me yeah that's a good thing yeah
first of all i don't appreciate you
mentioning my burner
what was the name of your character does
your character have a name uh dirtbag
deb
that's really good yeah
what do you want to do let's call dirt
back together
it's like you're hanging out you've got
nothing to do dirt turn back dabs around
on a tuesday let's call them dirtbag
dab's a good time she's yeah
but you can't get her get rid of her but
she'll never judge you yes
oh my god dirtbag hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else